knowing you personally i feel that a lot
of your lack of confidence
stemmed from a certain event you had
with
another internet personality namely
leafy like i've already explained the
bear
like the overall story from my
perspective but what was it like for you
like being in one of his videos and
being called out by him
oh well obviously that plays a large
part as well and like my lack of
confidence also i just don't think i'm a
very confident person
but with the leafy thing how did it all
start like what was the like how did you
when did when did you make that video
and then
uh i made that video actually because i
you know how obviously i used to be that
predictable kind of
weeby cringe girl up until i think the
first time i went to japan
right and um then i came back from japan
and i looked at myself i'm like what the
[ __ ] was wrong with me
and that's when i made that video kind
of as like oh my god like people like
this exact poking fun yeah
[ __ ] fun it was kind of like a satire
it was too good though
it was way too real you understood your
core audience
way too well when i first saw that i
thought it was legit
yeah yeah um but and then like this one
creepy guy kept re-uploading it and like
he kept uploading to 4chan and obviously
yeah and then i deleted it when i was
like 17 because i was like i don't want
this so
how long was it up before you deleted it
about a day and a day
like a few days maybe but not it was not
up long
it just like blew up straight away no
and then um a few years later
like i haven't been doing youtube in a
bit i was just like still like in
england
and then i get this notification from
this girl uh that i knew and
like who kind of like goes on for a
chance stuff like that
um and she said hey this video is this
video of you and it was
me obviously it was a video um and it
had about 60 000 views and i'm just like
initially i was pretty like embarrassed
i didn't feel good like to me at 60 000
views at that time
yeah and then i kind of like felt pretty
shitty about that but then not even a
week later
i wake up in the middle of the night to
my phone just constantly vibrating with
all of these messages from people i went
to high school with people i've met
maybe once or twice
all on facebook all on you know sky
twitter just
everywhere of like hey you're in a leafy
video and you're pretty cringe and
this is like at the peak of leafy yeah
this is actually his most viewed video
ever
is it actually really [ __ ] how many
views does it have uh it had
last time i checked like 20 million oh
something like that
it was a lie and um just and it sucked
because i
woke up to hundreds of emails of people
telling me to kill myself
and this lasted for months yeah because
i i remember every time like every
because how the ball kept rolling was
that
every time like the comments would start
to die down there would be another
cringe compilation
and it was the cringe compilations that
kept this going on for so long
because it appeared in the leafy video
which was just like which just lit the
[ __ ] fire yeah
and then he got you got all the leafy
fans and then as soon as like like we
we you basically hot hell holed up in
like a bunker and just like
kept away from the internet and as soon
as you like came out another
cringe compilation would come out and
then i'd be getting
i still even to this day people i know
message me like
with the video like hey i just saw you
in a cringe compilation and kind of like
slightly make fun of me and
obviously it doesn't feel initially for
years like of course like i
i like it was awful like i didn't touch
my phone i would cry a lot i went
through a pretty bad period not gonna
lie like i was pretty
it was awful and no amount of words or
like any
kind of emotion i could show you now
could show you how
terrible it kind of was oh i mean just
imagining it
is just [ __ ] hard yeah no it was
terrible because i i can't imagine
it gets the point where people i knew
from like my hometown people who like
didn't know about like anime and stuff
like i think that was a point
when i remember it was like really hit
you that man this has gone really far
when you're
with high school friends person because
like that's 20 million views on one
video but on all those
compilations those like yeah it could
easily be up to like 100 million
exactly and yeah yeah uh a lot of
[ __ ] people
obviously talking about it now like it
doesn't feel great but i think
i've of course it's been so long i've
accepted it you know when people say
like oh you're really like
say insults i'll be like dude like who
the [ __ ] are you like i don't give a
[ __ ]
i mean i think the fact that you've
managed to like live through that and
still being like
i still want to like stay on the
internet i think it's pretty [ __ ]
communication
i know i would immediately leave the
indians yeah yeah that was very i
definitely
almost didn't even try with youtube
because like aren't really like
i mean i don't blame you like i think
anybody would be like no never going on
i mean it took
a lot of convincing to try and get
sydney back on the internet and it was
it was something where i i knew
that sydney had a personality that could
like succeed on youtube or just it was
just
trying to convince her that hey just
ignore all these comments that you've
been hearing over the past of the haters
yeah
[ __ ] the haters [ __ ] the haters [ __ ]
they hate comments um
and just like just just be you because i
don't like one thing i can appreciate
about
sydney is that she doesn't know how to
be anyone but herself
like what you see is like what you get
so like
that that like can also backfire
sometimes where
you know people don't know where like
people like you know people
think you know where like the cringe
compilation and stuff like that
yeah but you know you're you're where
you are now and i think you're doing
pretty [ __ ] well
yeah i mean if there's one thing i can
say you're a personality sydney
you are definitely a personality
congrats on being a personality
you made it dude i felt so bad because i
remember like i don't know if you
remember this but uh
i i didn't know you but i knew you
because of voice acting right do you
remember yesterday
dude i felt so bad about this but now i
don't give a [ __ ] i know it was like no
use
yeah so i i knew silly from voice acting
and so when i met sydney when i first
saw her in person
i was like oh [ __ ] it's her
you're like hey and that was that was
like the reaction that sydney like was
so scared of because there'd be so many
times where we'd be walking around and
she'd just
see like a person like turn around and
she's like yeah absolutely would be like
you know you know we need to leave we
need to leave right now
oh god oh god not the greatest sort of
like oh i'm a celebrity but more of like
oh [ __ ]
yes i need the other pair of sunglasses
i
first met sydney and then i realized
that it was her and i asked her i was
like city are you
like cringe girl i think i said that and
you were like you said that
i was just looking down and like i'm
never gonna talk to this guy again was
like
i have no idea what compelled me to ask
you i think like as i was talking to you
it just came in my head and i was like
say it connor say it [ __ ] say it
i don't know why i would never do that
normally i would normally go home and
[ __ ] analyze
enhance you know but yeah i asked you
and then i remember when you told the
story the first time about how hard it
was i was like oh [ __ ]
that's awesome jokes about it i feel
like i don't know him well enough to
tell him to stop
because i don't mind now obviously but
back then i was like
because because it's weird for me
because i found out about the whole
leafy thing
after yeah yeah so like when i first met
you
all i knew you was god's partner yeah
yeah so it was really like
weird hearing that story like afterwards
because i don't know if you told me or
someone else told me
maybe i think maybe i think it was gonna
be first it's probably when he first met
yeah hi i'm the chris
i think i got you drunk enough by the
way i was in a leafy video
like something came up in like you were
like oh do you do stuff online i'm like
no like maybe you see
at that time yeah and i don't know maybe
it's because i wasn't on youtube as
much at the time like i was on youtube
but i wasn't going around watching
other youtubers at the time i'm like
cripplingly addicted to youtube yeah and
also like at that point as well i hadn't
been on 4chan in years right so i didn't
know what the [ __ ] was happening over
there as well so then when i saw that
video
after you told me about it i was like oh
okay this is the video people are
talking about but i think
yeah but it was really weird like i
don't know if i'm maybe the first one
i think you actually were like you're
the first only person who's just like
didn't know all right if it's any
conversation i don't think it was that
bad
thank you
i thought it was pretty obvious to me
but i guess i think it's because it's
anime people like anime's cringe yeah
that's why especially back then as well
yeah